[Music]
coming up next book TV presents
afterwards an hour-long interview
program where we invite guest hosts to
interview authors this week Columbia
Journal editor Gary Leach talks about
his new book Beyond bogota diary of a
drug war journalist in colombia in the
book mr. leach provides a first-hand
account of the Colombian government's
us-supported war on drugs and the
guerrilla groups and farmers who make up
its targets mr. leach discusses his book
with Josh rushing correspondent hey Gary
thanks for joining us let's talk about
beyond bogota your time in covering the
drug war down in colombia but let's step
back a little bit and set up the the
playing field here what happened in
colombia with a la valencia what's
set-up the current situation
well Colombia's violence in its current
form has basically been going on since
the 1940s when a populist leader was
assassinated in 1948 and that led to a
civil war between the two or followers
of the two dominant political parties
the liberals and conservatives and out
of that decade of violence which killed
about 200,000 Colombians emerged mostly
peasant groups who would defend
themselves against government repression
who actually started seeking broader
structural changes and many of them
became socialist or communist advocates
and these peasant groups ended up taking
a bombs initially just to defend
themselves against the army and by 1964
they actually officially became the
Revolutionary Armed Forces of Colombia
or the FARC guerrilla movement was a che
a part of that are connected with that
at all or an influence on that he wasn't
so much an influence actually change in
his Motorcycle Diaries was in Colombia
in the middle of la violencia which this
decade of violence through the 50s was
called
and he did no in the motorcycle dive is
that that Colombia experienced more
repression in Colombia is more overt
invisible than any other country he'd
traveled through on that journey and so
that that was a reflection of the
conditions that led to this peasant
movements becoming forming the
guerrillas as I see known as the FARC
which today is the largest guerrilla
movement in Colombia and separate from
the FARC you also have the ELN what was
the ELN there the ELN that the National
Liberation Army that they also formed in
1964 officially but they were more than
Monessen of most of the guerrilla groups
that formed throughout Latin America
following the Cuban Revolution they were
more influenced by Che and Fidel Castro
they were there were more urban
intellectuals who went to the
countryside to form guerrilla armies
whereas the FARC predates the Cuban
Revolution its roots are in in the early
to mid fifties and it it very much is a
peasant based guerrilla organization
which the ELN is is more urban
intellectual lead and then to confuse
things even more there's another side of
this equation that isn't the government
in the military that's the the
paramilitaries so how did they fit in
exactly throughout the history of
Colombia's violence there's always been
paramilitary groups that have come and
gone and and these groups work often
hand-in-hand with the military the
latest wave of paramilitaries in
Colombia emerged in the early eighties
and they were formed by initially the
big drug cocaine cartels the Medellin
Cartel the Cali cartel and ostensibly to
defend themselves against the and their
family members against kidnapping by the
guerrillas but the military and large
landowners also formed paramilitary
organizations to defend their economic
interest from the guerrillas and the
military to wage a dirty war against not
only the guerrillas but any peasants
believed to be sympathizers of the
guerrillas and anyone on the Left
basically whether you're politician
unionists human rights defenders
community organizers and the
paramilitaries worked hand in glove with
the Colombian military and they did the
dirty work or a lot of the dirty work
for the Colombian military and
throughout the eighties and nineties
they were primarily responsible for most
of the human rights abuses particularly
the massacres well why do they call the
the dirty war because of that because
the massacres and what massacres are you
talking about
the the the actual combat traditional
combat takes place between either the
power militaries and the guerrillas or
the army and the guerrillas but there's
also a dirty war in Colombia it's called
dirty because it's the targeting of
civilians unarmed civilians and again
that's primarily been carried out
through the 80s 90s by the power
managers and what it is is they see
anyone who who works for social change
as a subversive as a communist anyone
that challenges the government's
policies speaks out against the
government or tries to organize social
movements in any way non-violently
they're automatically assumed to be
guerrillas guerrilla sympathizers and so
the dirty war is the targeting of these
citizens the Colombians who are working
non-violently to change the the
political social and economic structures
of the country ok so that's that's the
stage well you have a bit of loud
background right you're from to two
places to tell us a little bit about
that I was born in in England and my
formative years were in England they
left when I was 15 and moved from
Manchester England to Detroit that's a
big time yeah or one industry or city to
another but yeah the cultural shift and
the 15 that's a tough time to move like
that but that big of a cultural shift
right yes it was a had my last two years
in high school in Detroit and yeah I
wasn't happy with a move it was you know
I felt like an outsider 15 you know
everyone's got their cliques already
their friends and where I moved to most
of the people had been you know going
through the school system together the
whole life so so I never found a clique
I was kind of an outsider and so when I
graduated you know my first instinct was
to get out of there so and yeah I did
again
an adventurous spirit so I just decided
okay I'm going to take off and I've
never been to the west coast so Los
Angeles is where where I headed to just
foot sense of adventure you know I had
no career and goals or ambitions at that
time I didn't know what I wanted to do
with my life so I guess it was the
traditional you know I'm gonna go out
and find myself or something but so I
ended up in Los Angeles and then decided
I wanted to go further straight but had
no money this was in 1979 and and
actually a friend I met in Los Angeles
was a former Marine and talking to him
and I decided you know what why not why
not enlist in the Marines and see if I
can get sent overseas and experience a
different country and when you were a US
citizen not at that time no I hadn't
become a citizen yet I became a citizen
later on but at that time I still a
British citizen so you're British Tufts
and enlisting and the most extreme of
the Armed Services and I say that as a
former Marine yeah
that's an odd thing right yeah and and
again for me it was it was this I guess
the sense of adventure I was I was out
there seeking adventure I wasn't sure
what I wanted to do I just wanted I knew
I wanted to be out there in the world
experiencing different things and as you
say the most extreme of the the u.s.
armed force is a which as much a cult as
a military service exactly and it and
again fit my personalities like because
my exact thinking was okay if I'm going
to join the military it's going to be
the one that's the most challenging and
so that was what did you ever wonder if
you join the army would you always
wonder if you could have made it as a
Marine it thought about yeah exact I
donno because I wouldn't saw the other
recruiters and it to me was like yeah
you know I'll always wonder if I could
have made it through the Marines so you
were in the Marines for a few years yeah
and then you get out yeah how did you
find yourself down to this this Columbia
thing so attracted to what was going on
there well it is the Marines that
introduced me to Latin America because I
was stationed in Panama I got my
overseas posting and I got to experience
you know a different culture and animal
was fascinating but you know I I
realized it was a place because the
Canal Zone was still in existence at the
time this is 1980 that was very
influenced and dominated
bye-bye Americans guess 34,000 military
personnel there and civilians so when I
got out the Marines I decided I want to
go back and experience more of Central
America at that time and you know
because my curiosity had been raised and
so so actually I traveled down from
Detroit down to Panama and back
basically hitchhiking taking buses and
on a three-month trip half of it was
with my brother my brother done and but
when I returned I was traveling alone
you got yourself in a bit of trouble
there yeah we would become a theme in
your life as you write about me yeah
maybe I need to told someone about that
but you have segments in your life that
seem to exist in between periods of
captivity yeah you know exactly which
should be a warning to you right now
exam it to Colombia next week but are
you really here well tell us about about
this time in what was it was El Salvador
yeah yes it was it was it early 1982 and
the the civil war there was at its
height yeah right in the middle so
exactly and I was traveling back heading
back to the United States and I came to
the board under salvador border and at
the checkpoint there i handed them my
passport and they started rifling
through my backpack and they found a
book of poetry by the singer Patti Smith
Ashley and and it never entered my mind
but just inside the cover of the book
there's a black and white photo of her
in a t-shirt holding a walkie-talkie
which it just never entered my mind
during the trip that could be perceived
negatively you know I was pretty naive
at the time probably a lot of people I
you know when think what pictures were
in this book as I'm crossing a border
everything that was just the other photo
is what it was sure and like I can't
imagine me being held accountable for
you know that picture on this book it's
just a book I happen to have exactly
didn't enter my mind and so but to the
the the border guards they looked at it
and decided now speaking English that
this was revolutionary or subversive
literature and so they detained me could
they read English no they didn't speak
English no healing with Patti Smith
who's a famous you know fairly famous
Paul
Rockstar thought that magic pot doesn't
have a big following down and else I
know in 1982 you know you didn't have
cable TV's they didn't have em TV of
anything so then he had no idea who she
was and and they just it was all based
on the photograph and so they detained
me and basically they detained me and
then it was up to then after that some
commander to decide I guess you know
whether to release me or now the slave
stood one of the more horrific stories
in the book I thought because I'm
putting myself in your shoes I I'm not
sure how I would have handled it or
dealt with it or continued you know to
carry that with that with me tell us
what happened while you were detained it
don't even in Nicaragua more than right
yeah absolutely
yeah the the army what they did was they
took me to a military base in in Laguna
on in in the south of El Salvador and
there's a big big military base and
basically what they did is they took
shoelaces not mine it just shoelaces and
they tie your thumbs together you know
right around here with shoelaces behind
your back and then the blind it
blindfolded me and eventually at the end
of the first day there my second day
detention they took me to a room put me
in the room and I managed to work my
blindfold free on the wall and there was
a Nicaraguan woman a middle-aged
Nicaraguan woman in the in the room with
me I'm just curious how could you tell
she was no problem at first I assumed
all had some kind of conversation but
then oh no because we were transported
from the border to this base together in
the back of a pickup truck and I heard
her then referred to her as [ __ ] around
okay yeah actually I didn't talk to her
in the whole time she never said a word
to me in this several days we spent
together she was just so terrified so I
got my blindfold off and then in the
morning and the soldiers came in they
brought us some breakfast and some beans
and rice and thankfully they weren't
upset that my blindfold was off she she
also had her thumbs tied behind her back
was blindfolded and there's no furniture
in the room where
we were you know both had to lie in a
red tile floor and they ended up done so
that we could eat the breakfast and they
left us there we ate breakfast they came
back when they came back though she'd
gone into the bathroom and they came
back they tied my films together behind
my back again and they went into the
into the bathroom after hit and and yeah
I could hear her crying sobbing noises
and their voices and and there was yeah
they were raping him in the bathroom and
and yeah i sat there and it's like you
know what do you what do you do I
there's two things basically I could do
I could either go in there and try and
make some kind of scene or call for help
or but my thoughts on that were if I do
that and I call for help
what's to say that the other soldiers
that come won't just join in participate
and make it worse for her I mean there's
not exactly no one to turn to that in
that situation so you know I sat there
and just figured that you know do
nothing and which was you know is there
an awful feeling a hope a horrible thing
I've been helpless and so close or
something like that and you can hear it
yeah is that something that stays with
you or do you have these kind of
experiences that stay with you yeah I
mean a several over the years have from
that and from my work as a journalist
that they're yeah they do stick with you
and particularly all the time then you
know not to jump too far ahead in your
story but you end up travelling in these
fairly dangerous places with your your
wife or soon-to-be wife at the time
ustym ajan that you would flash back and
think you know what kind of situation am
i getting her into because you know how
bad it can get that that was one of my
biggest concerns with with my my wife
work with me she's worked with me in
three occasions in Colombia the only
reason that I was at all comfortable
with it is because she has a history of
working in Nicaraguan El Salvador and
the nine is investigating political
issues in post-conflict years but very
in the field fluent in Spanish so but
she'd never been in the conflict zones
that we went into but my my concern
wasn't so much her and how she'd respond
and and she responded wonderfully it was
how the groups would respond to her and
exactly that my big fear of course is
rape I mean if they say it's a weapon in
war and it's and you know it's something
that obviously women have to worry about
much greater degree than the nurse it's
not really a concern for us in making a
position now where you can't stop at our
protector or exactly it's if you have
anyone's worst nightmare exactly because
if you went into an armed group and they
decide to to do something like that yeah
you're helpless I mean you just cannot
so to come back you're detained in El
Salvador we'll leave how you get out of
that one for for people to actually read
the book but how do you get sucked into
Colombia and it seems to be Colombia you
start off with kind of general interest
in Latin America yeah
but it ends up being just Colombia well
how does that happen that narrowing
happen yeah
later in aid is and at this time I was
in El Salvador means I was very a
political person you know I didn't grow
up interested in politics I had no
interest in geopolitics u.s. foreign
policy these that was one of the
experiences that started you know my
political awakening especially about
u.s. role in Latin America and in the
late 80s essentially okay stop right
there because just because I relate to
that as someone who's forced to look go
overseas and at some point look back at
America and it's even interesting a
similarity in terms of were built
Marines so we're coming from pretty
strong sense of what America is to be
input into this foreign paradigm and
having to look back and say oh that's
what we look like to the rest of the
world that's what's happening when we
engage that the rest of will because
when you come from the Marines it's
clearly we're the good guys know exactly
we go around we free people who need to
be freed we provide humanitarian
assistance we're the good guys here and
so it really curious about that process
that evolution and thinking and what you
saw that start sort of making kind of
question that this this I think very
simple way of looking at it
again the first step was ourselves as I
say in the book the the you know I've
been thoroughly socialized to believe
that you know Western democracy in the
US democracy British democracy
represented all that was good in the
world you know and as in the Marines
you're indoctrinated with that too you
know a much deeper degree than the
average citizen and so I went to El
Salvador my assumption was I knew you
know I didn't know much was going on in
Salvador and I was traveling through
there but I did know the US was
supporting the Salvadoran army against
Marxist guerrillas so therefore they are
mission the good guys well it's
particularly within the context of the
Cold War right a cure yeah but then you
know when I started seeing some of the
things I saw when I was captive there
and and the way these people were
treated the Salvadorans by the soldiers
that that my taxpayers were funding and
then as I when I got out of there and I
started looking into El Salvador
realizing that the by far the greatest
violated human rights there was the u.s.
funded Salvadoran army it you know it
started making me question you know
everything I'd been socialized and that
I'd never questioned before and then
when I went back to Latin America in the
late 80s and it was my first trip to to
Colombia and and again everyone told me
Colombia's dangerous is violent don't go
there and so I was very wary when I went
there and it turned out to be one of the
most you know who spent five days there
that time but you know every most people
incredibly friendly the hospitality that
the warmth the generosity the country
was beautiful it was it was the most
extreme opposite to any place I visited
when can contracted to what I expected
and from there I went into the
Ecuadorian I'm just what you're saying
of all places you've been to you went
into Colombia with a very strong idea
what it was going to be and couldn't
have been more surprised yeah I think I
probably had a preconception of Colombia
a stronger preconception of Colombia
than any other country I've ever visited
and again from all in negative and
Colombia still gets that negative image
that negative press and other travelers
who told me in Central America
there is dangerous and so I was very
very wary when I traveled through there
in Panama to Ecuador and yet it was the
exact opposite
the magical place though isn't it I mean
you can see why song like Gabriel Garcia
Marquez would come out of a place like
that that kind of magical realism I mean
it looks like Narnia I mean things
happen there you can't imagine happening
anywhere else in the world it you have
to really just your sense of what
reality is almost when you're in
Colombia and unless you're why it's that
way but it sure seems to be that way
from my experiences there yeah I can't
nail exactly what it is as well other
than to a great degree the people but
there is an amazing warmth and energy to
come it is mesmerizing it is
otherworldly in a truly absorbing way
and it's amazing how many people I meet
who go to Colombia and and just fall in
love with the country you know it's it's
it's it it does it gets into you get it
gets into your and the more you go there
the more time you spend there the more
it just becomes a part of you when did
you become a journalist in hell well the
I went to Ecuador from Colombia on that
ship and there I visited indigenous
communities in the Amazon I was
traveling down through the rivers of the
amazon and indigenous community in
particular that I visited had been
devastated by a US oil company at a
survival first devastated their culture
neighs departure when the oil ran out
just after you devastated okay you
explain how that happens I think there's
an ocean in the US that all companies go
down they provide jobs and could pay
they build some infrastructure they pay
for the natural resources they're taking
out what was your experience though well
this I arrived this village and there
was only a handful of people left in it
it was virtually abandoned and had been
that way for most a year and the stories
they told me was that the oil company
came I think it's about 15 years earlier
and they'd found oil there and they told
the people listen you don't need to to
do you you know you live your
subsistence lifestyle is anymore
we'll provide you with work we'll pay
you will bring in all the food you need
the drinks you need everything and it
this is how it will be from now on and
and the indigenous community accepted
that and they bought into it and that's
the way life was for the next 15 years
and then the oil ran out and the oil
company a year before I got there
upped and left and now their lands were
put and the streams were polluted they
they forsaken their traditional
lifestyle the young that had grown up in
this 15 years had no interest in going
back to the traditional lifestyle but
they had no way of surviving as a
community anymore so many of them left
and started going to the cities to try
and you know we capture this this modern
world that that they'd experienced and a
handful stayed behind and we're trying
to survive and and it was one of the
most depressing experiences I've ever
had to see that the destruction of this
culture and that was another along with
our salvador another major major step in
my political awakening was with the role
of corporations multinational
corporations in these countries were you
John also photographer you know
and it was after that that then I
decided it in the nine is that I wanted
to focus on work now that had related to
Latin America and I've always enjoyed
writing boys it's always cumulative ly
easy to me and and I like the
investigative the traveling the
investigative exploring aspect of it so
and I was now becoming very interested
in US policy in the region so all of
those combined I just decided that you
know journalism was was what I wanted to
do and I wanted to focus on US policy in
Latin America if you weren't a
journalist and you're visiting a
community like that it's pretty far off
the beaten path oh yeah
how did that happen or why were you just
looking to get off the beaten path as a
tip Venturer yeah it is adventurous part
of me and one place that I've always
wanted to visit my whole life was the
Amazon rainforest and and and I didn't
just want to go into
you know by Road or plane in this little
community in just a that I wanted to
experience it so so I you know I
purchased a dugout canoe and a paddle
from an indigenous family and just took
off through the jungle in in my canoe
and stay with indigenous families along
the way so he's an adventurer it was
like to me the ultimate adventure the
one I'd always wanted to do you didn't
speak their language well most of them
spoke Spanish on the main rivers there
but there were other clans that that
were more than no they didn't
philosophically looking back in the
situation with the the tribe and the oil
company is it naive to expect anything
else to happen I mean has a train
already left the station and on on how
much the Western world needs oil not
just the Western world and China and in
the industrialized nation needs oil is
it naive to expect that companies won't
go after oil is it or do they just need
me more responsible in the way that they
do it and more responsible in the way
that they pull out when the oil is gone
I think it's naive to expect them to not
do it whether people are against
exploitation of oil particularly in
indigenous lands can succeed and stuff
in the Malloys isn't is another question
but yeah with our dependence on oil this
what I experienced in Ecuador is is
going on around the world now because
the oil companies are trying to locate
oil everywhere they can they trying to
exploit it and it's in the last 15 20
years that's led because that's led to a
lot more conflicts between oil companies
and traditional communities indigenous
communities and and it's happening
throughout Latin America in Africa and
Asia and so it it doesn't bode well for
indigenous communities in the long run
the only potential thing that could save
their coaches as if we do move away from
oil to more renewable energy forms in
the near future if that somehow happens
it you have to wonder if that would
happen in time I mean it's hard to
imagine it's one of the interesting
things in the book is that this I travel
a lot in the Middle East as well and do
stories out of there and
the similarities that you point out I
mean not just the conflict but the fact
that it's over oil of all things it
starts to sound a lot like the Middle
East but the Middle East gets so much
more attention in the States
yeah the root of Columbia's conflict is
the country's resources it's you know
it's not discussed enough it's not
focused on enough we focus on the drugs
we focused on we focus on on the leftist
guerilla Strine overthrow the government
the ideology the drugs these issues but
it's rooted in resources Colombia is a
very resource rich country its top to
exports are oil and coal it's one of the
top 12 suppliers of oil to United States
it's the number one foreign supplier of
coal to the United States it's the
world's leading producer of emeralds 40%
of the world's emeralds are mined in
colombia how does the cocaine trade
compare to a material they export well
cocaine is its leading export and larger
than oil yeah oil is the largest legal
export and so and then in the end the
midst of this you've got the cocaine as
well trade but resources is a huge
component in in the conflict and US
policy has secured access to those
resources for multinational corporations
and under the process of economic
globalization Colombia's resources have
been opened up to foreign investment and
Plan Colombia the counter narcotics
initiative the US backed
counter-narcotics initiative is failed
miserably as a counter narcotics
initiative it's had quite a bit of
success as a counterinsurgency
initiative which is push the guerillas
away out of resource resource which
regions and provided security in those
regions for multinational corporations
to come in and take advantage of the new
economic policies okay at that that's a
great place for us to stop for a while
but we need to take a break but we come
back we're going to talk a lot more
about Plan Colombia okay afterwards and
several other c-span programs are
available for download as podcasts or
with Gary leech and John rushing in a
moment
in 1979 America's cable companies
created c-span as a public service now
30 years later c-span continues as the
political network of record bringing you
the three c-span television networks
c-span radio and c-span org afterwards
with Gary Leach and John rushing
continues just before break you opened a
big can of worms here you brought up
playing Colombia that this is a major
shift in what's happening in Colombia
what it has happened there in the last
say five years tell us kind of back up
and tell us about the roots of Plan
Colombia and then then what it is well
the United States has been fighting a
drug war in Colombia since the early
eighties against the cocaine trade
initially was against the big cartels
medicine in Cali throughout the aid is
the first half in the 90s and us drug
policy was primarily focused on
targeting the drug trafficking
organizations and interdiction efforts
to stop the cocaine getting to the
United States Klein Columbia result in a
dramatic shift in the u.s. approach and
it coincided with growing strength of
the FARC guerrillas each of the big
trafficking organizations have been
dismantled by the mid nineties and what
he emerged we placed them was a whole
bunch of what's been called micro cartel
smaller cartels most of them linked to
the right-wing paramilitaries so rather
than two big ones you've got a whole
plethora of small ones it's ensuring
that that happens right at the end of
the Cold War where instead of being two
great superpowers you end up having you
know the order of kind of chaos scissors
seems like same things happening there
where they might become our yeah that's
much more difficult more complex to
understand and tend to come back yeah
there's more difficulty on that at the
same time coca cultivation historically
it occurred in Peru and Bolivia where
the plant the coca plant that produces
the leaves that the raw ingredient
cocaine and then the leaves were
processing the coca
which was then transported to Columbia
where all the cocaine labs were and that
was processed into cocaine and then
shipped out at Columbia well in the nine
is there was a shift and more and more
coca started being cultivated in
southern Colombia by Colombian farmers
displaced peasants from the the Andean
Highlands started colonizing the Amazon
region cutting down the rainforest
growing coca in order to survive and
this the FARC taxed coca growers
particularly the big coca coca growers
and they taxed any drug processing labs
in their territory in any traffickers
who wanted to come in and get the
cocaine out it is kokanee go in Colombia
on any level because it improve it as a
destroying for last year where I was
putting some cocaine labs and coke is
legal there and it's actually been
celebrated in their culture to use for
coca teas to choose to the least that
kind of thing as coca legal at all in
Colombia it's nothing it's not the same
as in Peru and Bolivia there are a few
indigenous cultures in Colombia that do
use it traditionally but it's very very
small amount of indigenous do that the
it's not legal for anyone else and the
overwhelming majority of coca that's
cultivating in Colombia is by by
peasants not non-indigenous peasants and
and it is for the cocaine trade not fair
for the this maybe was a lot of the
cocaine trade is shifting to Peru
because they can't fumigate down there
because people have a right to grow it
exactly have to sell some of it to the
state not go state organization to buy
some and resources for T T so it becomes
more convoluted issue improve that in
Colombia and I would argue that it's not
shifting to Peru because coca
cultivation in Colombia is increasing so
it's just growing up rose it's just
going into as well it's just spreading
and expanding this is even true
throughout play in Colombia that the
each year even the US government by its
own measurement says exactly the cocoa
growth is growing here the objective or
Plan Colombia emerged because the FARC
guerrillas gained military strength from
their funding they got from taxing the
coca trade in the drug trade so they
they grew
from about three and a half thousand
fighters at the end of the eighties to
about eighteen thousand on Fridays by
the end of the 90s this is where the
term Darko terrorist comes from exactly
NACA guerrillas narco-terrorists it was
NACA grill is more at that time it came
knock at Arras more after 9/11 sure but
the weather you said that were
terrorists you can go right to 9/11 and
then see how it's used for politics and
money afterward how exactly so the fog
became this formidable military force by
the end of the 90s they controlled about
40% of the national territory they were
attacking the Colombian army bases in
southern Colombia and taken over the
entire bases they're not traditional
guerrilla warfare just ambushing patrols
right a thousand guerrillas would at a
time would attack vases do they have
helicopters or heavy equipment I mean
what no machine guns on trucks probably
no to not really any trucks it just a
key 47s and heavy machine guns and
mortars homemade mortars and stuff like
that and they're attacking military
bases exactly so Plan Colombia at this
time shifted or the u.s. your policy
shifted its focus this time away from
the drug traffickers which were
primarily linked with the right-wing
paramilitaries and decided to start
targeting coca growers most of which
were in southern Colombia in areas
controlled by the FARC guerrillas and
this happens in 2003 which everyone
knows 2003 is a year the u.s. invaded
Iraq right well no this this shift
happened in the late nineties oh that
yeah this was the formation of Plan
Colombia I said which a mission which
came into being in 2000 okay and so the
objective of Plan Colombia was the
target coca growers more than
traffickers and which and US military
aid under Plan Colombia starting in 2000
made Colombia the third largest
recipient of US military aid in the
world only Israel and Egypt received
more and that's been the case ever since
2000 and so all this US military aid
creating a 3,000 strong counter
narcotics brigade in the Colombian
military providing Colombia with more
than 60 Huey and Blackhawk helicopters
to make the army more mobile and of
course fighting the drug trade in the
file control regions inevitably
inevitably meant fighting the FARC
so a lot of critics say Plan Colombia is
more about counterinsurgency than
counter-narcotics and the the
counter-narcotics idea was just the the
guy is the excuse to sell it to Congress
and the American people as a drug policy
rather than saying we're becoming deep
more deeply engaged in the civil
conflict did the park make a strategic
mistake there and getting mixed up with
with drug trade and then that brought in
the u.s. yes to some degree although the
FARC if they'd gotten that strong
without the drug trade would have bought
in the u.s. I believe but it is why why
would the u.s. strategically care about
what the park is doing in Colombia who
cares of 40 percent of coffee goes over
to some other group for the same reasons
they did in in well not so much to forty
percent but the threaten that the
threatening goes to the state Colombia
is a close ally to the United States and
the same way the u.s. fought against the
the the leftist guerrillas in El
Salvador against the Sandinistas and
Sandinista government in Nicaragua
Guatemala the same GOP politics even
though it's post Cold War this was
happening under under the Clinton
administration yes but it seems to be a
leftover from the Reagan administration
exactly it's the same the same
ideological approach you know a combat
leftist guerrillas the same drug war
approach a militaristic drug war
approach and Clinton administration were
the ones that formulated Plan Colombia
and the objective of Plan Colombia was
the counter-narcotics objective was to
reduce coca cultivation in Colombia by
50% in five years and today we're now
eight years into Plan Colombia coca
cultivation in Colombia is higher today
than it was when Plan Colombia was
initiated in 2000 as you said even
according to the United State
Department's own statistics so is there
any sense of accountability in the
States is anyone asking why do we keep
giving them so much money if what we're
set out to do do it is failing
yeah there's a lot of organizations that
are working on drug issues that are
doing that and there's some in Congress
that are too but the overwhelming
majorities just keep moving ahead with
the drug war
again we know in the United States it's
it's a liability politically to appear
soft on drugs so so the Congress
congressional representatives voting for
Plan Colombia they can say we've been
tough on drugs and another problem with
it is that the the aid we call it aid
for Colombian it's it's between half and
three quarters of a billion dollars a
year seventy five percent of that is
military aid very little of the money
goes to Colombia it's going to you know
companies in the US in different states
so you know the Blackhawk helicopters
are built in Connecticut so that's
that's federal dollars coming in to
representatives from Connecticut their
constituency creating jobs for their
constituents Monsanto produces the
chemicals for the herbicides that's jobs
and federal dollars in that state and he
was a refurbished in in Texas so so the
money actually doesn't even lead it's
called aid for colombia but the monies
go to US corporations spread around the
US and so representatives in those
states where those companies are based
they have a vested interest in voting
for that plan for the sake of their
constituents to produce jobs regardless
of where the plankton Lumbee actually
works or not better ground I was down
there a couple years ago and I was with
the homeless and they they were trained
I went to their training base by Special
Forces guys special force former Special
Forces guy work for the embassy took me
out on submissions with him we flew on
blackhawk helicopters they wore us
uniforms that said Columbia on them yeah
they had m16s and m4s and m9 Berettas I
mean it it looked a lot like the Marines
frankly I didn't you style us helmets to
yeah same how it was almost nothing
different about him and I was a bit
shocked by that and I was also a little
surprised to find out that they were
under the police rather than army this
guys don't look anything like police
they look like Special Forces guys or
Marines what what was happening there
yeah I touched on that in the book too I
thought you didn't name the homeless no
but I read the police though yeah when
we when we think of police in general in
North America European nations we think
of some kind of of civil force that's
that's
able to municipal government or
provincial government or state
government that's not the case in
Colombia the national police in Colombia
administered by the Department of
Defense so in effect they're part of the
Colombian Armed Forces and and certain
units carbon arrows the humbler Zola
they are actually trained to engage in
combat and armed as you just described
and trained in in counterinsurgency and
deployed around the country so when we
hear news stories that FARC guerillas
killed police officers in Colombia we
have this vision of you know police
officers in their blue you know blue
uniforms with just a little hand go
directly in traffic yeah that's not the
case in Colombia that they're part of
the armed forces but the FARC do happen
to capture a lot of police officers
these guys are capturing and holding
hostage are they more like homeless
special forces kind of guys are they
more like the directing traffic variety
of cops that day more well they're not
is very in degrees at pleased that they
are some of them are trained to to fight
the guerrillas some are just regular
police but they're still a militaristic
police they still carry semi-automatic
weapons and stuff but that's who they
they're catching some some of this
embattled some of it's when they attack
towns and villages and they take over
the police station and and take them as
prisoners well before it gets too far
too much I want to come back to the FARC
let's go back what happened to the
paramilitaries what what's what's the
arc of their story as I said they formed
primarily in the aid is and they worked
with the military that they basically
they fought the dirty war for the
military so the military could say you
know that wash their hands with saying
we're not responsible for human rights
abuses the paramilitaries are how about
were those guys they were really bad
particularly through the 90s eight late
80s and nine is one example is in the
mid eighties the FARC studied peace
talks with the Colombian government they
called the ceasefire and the FARC along
with other leftist civil society groups
formed a political party the U P
and to engage in the political process
while negotiations were taking place
they actually have several Congress
people elected but the power militarism
ways the dirty war against this
political party because it was a
left-of-centre political party therefore
it was communist it was subversive and
in five years they virtually eradicated
it they assassinated more than two
thousand members including four elected
congressman and two presidential
candidates from the party on a personal
level you're detained a number of times
by FARC maybe ELN I don't remember time
military militaries definitely and
government forces occasionally of
different governments it seems we most
worried when it was the paramilitary
guys yes definitely yeah in the oil-rich
region about al khair in eastern
Colombia the paramilitaries detained me
there and they held me for four and a
half hours and and they took me to this
rural farm and they communicated with
through cell phone to their superior
somewhere in the country and basically
said we've got a gringo journalist what
you want us to do with him
and what was disconcerting for me with
that was whoever was making that
decision and they interrogated me for
four and half hours while he could until
we got the word back till they got that
decision well as that person could
easily go on the internet and start
looking at my work and you know my
investigations in Colombia have resorted
me being pretty critical of US policy of
Plan Colombia and how its devastating
the lives of peasants in Colombia and as
a result of that and I felt it's my job
as a u.s. journalist to to write for an
American audience to try and create
awareness of what American tax dollars
are being used for in Colombia and and
and the problems related to they use and
because part of that is we're funding a
military that is working closely with it
with a right-wing group that's on the US
State Department terrorist list and that
is the armed group that's responsible
for most of the human rights abuses and
massacres so so I've a lot of criticism
of the paramilitaries in my writing
you're not
that the u.s. is funding the
paramilitaries they're saying the u.s.
is putting a group that's letting the
paramilitaries do whatever they want
providing cover for them so they can do
whatever they want they weren't together
a lot of times the military secures
areas for the paramilitaries to go into
massacre
a village full of people that squats I
mean that exactly what they are is just
like an eighties right in Central
America the only difference is in
Colombia is the death squads in El
Salvador having tended to be people in
civilian clothes who would go out in the
night and then you know take people out
of their homes and kill them and dump
the bodies in Colombia the
paramilitaries until recently was
standing uniformed armies just like the
guerrillas the paramilitaries were like
12,000 strong by the year 2000 they were
in units military units all over the
country like a standing army so these
death squads were actually a uniform
standing army and they worked with the
Colombian Army and and who we were
funding so we were funding this army
that's working with right-wing
terrorists and after to 9/11 we're doing
it and in the name of fighting terrorism
so when I got the team by the
paramilitaries of course you know my
fear was they're going to go online
they're going to see what I've written
and and you know that may be the
decision what to do and they wouldn't be
favorable from my perspective I let you
go I mean do you think someone just
didn't do their homework and check
online or I mean look these why and I
thought like go out to do a good deed
today yeah I don't know either they
didn't do a serious check on me or they
did and decided they didn't want to harm
a foreign journalist in Colombia the
foreign journalist like in a way a
little better than the locals don't
touch yeah it's completely different
ballgame for foreign journalists and and
that's why I do ba the reason I do the
work I do my work is all in the role
conflict zones I don't work in the main
urban areas and the cities that most of
the mainstream foreign correspondents
cover that perspective from that area
this is the wrong complex zones and how
that the Royall Colombians are affected
by the conflict in US policies that is
grossly under reported and one reason is
most the foreign journalists don't go to
those regions they be
or basically from the capital the other
is Colombian journalist it's far too
dangerous for them
Colombian journalist is more than 30
killed in the last 20 years it's one of
the most dangerous countries in the
world to be a journalist yet far Angele
it's not not have been killed there's
been threats and couple going to exile
but my opinion on that is that the armed
groups don't want to create an
international incident by by killing
your foreign journalists and so for
whatever reason there's a certain
immunity there to some degree for
foreign journalists so I think it's our
responsibility to go in there and cover
these stories that Colombians plumbing
journalists can't cover the port of
clamp Plan Colombia wasn't justified the
drugs I mean it didn't you have senator
Graham from Florida saying that 40% or
45% of all terrorist acts against the
u.s. actually come from Colombia not the
Middle East yes as soon as 9/11 happened
within weeks you had people in Congress
and in the Bush administration who saw
an opportunity here to expand Plan
Colombia from being principally
operating in in regions where the drug
trade is occurring which is mostly
southern Colombia expanding that and
allowing freeing up all these supposedly
counter-narcotics resources and to
waging a war on terror against the FARC
it's the Fox on the state's list of
terrorist organizations and so you had
this move to start providing
counterterrorism training and aid to the
Colombian military to fight the FARC
under the war on terror and and what
restrictions did exist on plank Lumbee
aid restricted it to counter narcotics
operations were lifted that those
helicopters those kind of aquatics
troops and all the US aid from there on
in could be used to fight the FARC under
the war on terror so what you had is
emerging of the war on drugs and the war
on terror and Senator Graham was one of
the leading proponents of that and he
said Colombia is where most of the
terrorist attacks are taking place and
already failed to mention of course that
those terrorist attacks will by the
guerrillas against the operation
the US corporations oil companies
blowing up their pipelines it wasn't
against US citizens the year he referred
to another single US citizen was killed
by the FARC guerillas only it couldn't
to the profits of oil companies like
Occidental this is really actually have
you read Naomi Klein's
Shock Doctrine yes a new book it sounds
so much like that where that you have a
major incident happen that puts the
population in shock and then you have
leaders that are ready for that and
waiting for that and they take advantage
of it in a whole lot of ways that the
people don't quite realize but allow to
happen because of the shock created from
the first incident so 9/11 happens which
has nothing to do with Colombia exactly
but the leaders are prepared to pull
Colombia into that take advantage of it
and not just for US strategic interest
it sounds or maybe US strategic
interests are perfectly aligned with
these multinational companies but it
seems as if you a company like
Occidental and and the Canadian oil
companies that were ready to take
advantage of what happened when 9/11 is
that how you saw that go down yeah
duction definitely applied to that
situation in Colombia I mean it it not
to the degree that allowed them to
initiate something they weren't already
doing it allowed to an expansion of US
military intervention just taking
clothes off exactly take all the
restraints off and now now it's a
free-for-all under the under the guise
of the war on terror so they're going
very carefully worded and there's a very
specific thing that we're doing so point
9/11 happens and else we can do whatever
the hell we want yeah because plane
Colombia had to be presented to the
Congress US Congress as a
counter-narcotics initiative because the
Congress would never have passed a bill
a initiative like that that called for
the u.s. to become engaged in
counterinsurgency in Colombia 9/11 just
just just feed up the Bush
administration now under the war on
terror if they could get congressional
approval for anything so now they didn't
have to be concerned anymore of
presenting his accountant architects
initiative and and accounting a cottage
component you knows who is we mentioned
just failed miserably I mean it's it's a
fail I failed
strategy and yet we keep authorizing
another more than half a billion dollars
which will be every year in the plane
Columbia
okay so narcotics part fell but what's
worked well it it's it's it's furthered
us political and economic interest in
Columbia I think there's two things
particularly in this moment in time that
that plank Romanism
done for the u.s. one is it's it's got
the Colombian military to push the far
back into the really remote regions
because under the economic component of
Plan Colombia and under economic
globalization free market the free
market model is the country's been
resources have been opened up for
foreign investment now the economic
policies created favorable conditions
for foreign companies multinational
corporations mining companies oil
companies however there was no security
on the ground it's kind of like you back
you know you can create favorable
economic policies but if there's no
security on the ground these companies
won't go in there because they're just
going to get their employees killed
their infrastructure blown up
so what plank to Lum BIA and then
ensuing war on terror allow the earth to
do was to militarize these rural regions
and establish security on the ground for
multinationals to go in there and
exploit Colombia's resources and this is
what has made oil and coal the to legal
exports for Colombia used to be coffee
so a huge part of Colombia's booming
economy is it's now held up as a model
for economic growth and and security but
a huge part of that in foreign
investment is in resource extraction by
foreign corporations and so it's created
favorable conditions for multinational
corporations to operate in Colombia
the other thing it's done is its
strengthened the government of Colombia
which is a right-wing government and the
u.s. is closest ally in Latin America
and in Latin America's going to a shift
to the left right exactly Ecuador and as
well as we live
so given the context of what's happening
geopolitically in in South America
Colombia has become in the last decade a
very very important ally for the United
States well what's happened with the
FARC they're just the last year it's
been startling what's happened with the
FARC tell us some that and that's most
that's happened since you wrote the bulk
of this manuscript yes just in 2008 was
was the most devastating year for the
FARC militarily they've got they've had
a seven they have a seven-person
secretary or Central Command and in 40
years the Colombian military has never
succeeded in either capturing or killing
any of those seven leaders of the FARC
and then all of a sudden in March last
year they they kill they cut out all
dais the number two commander for the
far was that in Ecuador yeah he was his
camp was just over the border in equity
very few kilometers over the border and
your experience had the FARC gone back
and forth freely like we had safe haven
in Ecuador and conducted actions in
Colombia I'm sure they have and in fact
his camp the fact that comes to
Colombia's in Ecuador there is evidence
said that those borders he took in the
Amazon rainforest and you know it did
just it's just River travel is any way
you travel it there's no but what if
Ecuador doesn't look at that way they
look at us we're being pulled into the
drug war exactly I play in Colombia not
by the the FARC or within their borders
exactly no because it he fumigations
also tend to cross the border too so
yeah this board is a really porous and
really did you know it's why the
guerrilla warfare is so successful
encumber white and out to survive so
long it's the ideal terrain for
guerrilla warfare but when you were in
Reyes as camp but you talk about an
epilogue of the book was that an echo
door it was right around the border
again when you travel in this embassy I
don't know exactly where it is I you
know what I could gauge it was right
around the Colombia Ecuador aboard it
exactly which side of it you know I
couldn't tell so you have radios go down
and the bombing an army attack yeah you
have a sure shot he did supreme
commander who'd led them the entire
existence for over 40 years
he died about
heart attack later that month the same
month another one of this secretary was
killed by his bodyguard who then
deserted and then one of their major
strategies is the kidnapping strategy
they have won over 700 prisoners or
something like that in it's rumored yet
no one has exactly and and some of those
are our major prizes Ingrid Betancourt
former what presidential candidate yes
exact on tractors okay which by the
which were I think Dinah core or a
neighborhood NORC a Truman Northup grant
when I was there I oughta base or
dynacord workers were the ones doing the
fumigation is about seventeen military
contracting companies working in
Colombia um so but these three US
contractors and Ingrid Betancourt were
released with a daring plan with the the
Colombian army to get them out of there
some controversy about that and using a
human rights what is Red Cross after
well I don't want one of the one of the
undercover officers who were pretending
to be humanitarian worker had a Red
Cross a bib on problem with that is now
why would the FARC ever work with red
cross again yeah or trust up and
hopefully the Red Cross and they're
trying to do good deeds and so now
they're considered combatants if nothing
else well that's the danger that luckily
the fog haven't continued working with
the Red Cross but that that is the risk
it was like a parks on there hills
they are they've been pushed back I mean
I would estimate their control
territorial control has been reduced
from 40 to about 20 percent it's the
most remote regions they're definitely
on the defensive okay I want to talk to
you about this more I'm actually getting
to the part I want to talk about more
but it's my fault I left it to the end
we have to wrap pretty soon I want to
get at is if you rebate defeats the FARC
or leave them such a position that the
guy who's coming after him defeats the
FARC the eland doesn't hold much power
right now the paramilitaries are gone
and so you have what looks like maybe a
normal operating state in Colombia will
history side with Uribe and Plan
Colombia well if that scenario pans out
they probably will I don't think they
can militarily defeat the FARC
they've weakened them a lot but
basically they've taken the far back to
what they were the beginning of the
nineties
before the infusion of drug money
exactly in fact is still stronger than
the word beginning of the night is and
so the farc a week compared to a decade
ago but they're still stronger than they
were twenty years ago the Fox been
around for forty years
all right people gotta read your book
beyond Boca Carrie Thank You gage so
much best Bank here your son oh and
thanks for being here and afterwards
great thank you
take care